if I
did things like look out of the window
or
just anything that
I like to do and that was forbidden she
would go and
tell him about it and
get me into trouble which often led to
enormous explosions of anger and
a lot of beating and kicking and
other forms of violence
[Music]
what do you remember from early
childhood
my earliest memories were of a lot of
violence in the house
I grew up with my father well I didn't
know he was my father but and my mother
and
a few other people it was not the family
but it was a close commune which they
call the Communist Collective
at first it was kind of like a small
Communist party on a small scale
and as time went on it became more more
and more like a quasi-religious
organization
so there was less and less of the the
political aspect to it I mean that still
carried on but it became more of the
cult of personality
and he started to say that he would one
day become ruler of the world when China
took over from from the West
that is this is the way he used to talk
and it sounds absolutely crazy but
that's what I grew up believing
I don't know at what point but he
started to say also that he was actually
already
the ruler of the world
but that was in secret and that was why
the what he called the British fascist
state was always targeting him and
everybody was spying on him and
neighbors if they played loud music were
part of the fascia State's campaign to
disturb him and make his life difficult
and
and he became increasingly more paranoid
and saying bizarre things that people
were listening in to him when he's
talking
EB could leave the house on his own and
of course do whatever he wanted but the
other cult members always had to go in
in a pair they were not allowed to go on
their own except a couple of members who
were going out to work
how did you refer to the cult leader at
that point in time did you call him
father or dad
I was told to call him comrebala or a b
sometimes
I wasn't aware that he was my father or
that I had a mother I didn't know any
I'd even as a child I didn't know the
concept of father and mother I just
knew that this was Conor Bala and we had
to do as he said my mom didn't know that
she was pregnant until her Waters broke
so it was a shock to everybody when when
I was born
and a b
explained it to his wife and to the rest
of the cult members that there was
electronic warfare going on and that's
why
the baby was born
this woman called Sean who I later then
was my mother
in many ways she was crueler than
everybody else it was like she was
trying to prove that
her loyalty
to a b was more than her love for her
own daughter she had to prove to him
that she did not care about me at all so
she was the one who was always getting
me into trouble by saying that I had
done something that I hadn't done or
just anything the repercussions from
that were terrible I was just like left
in the room on my own and people went
out of the door and shut the door behind
them and held the door and left me on my
own
and that might not seem like such a bad
thing but in the context I was always
told that if I was on my own bad things
would happen to me that members of the
fascist state would come along and
take me away and do horrible harmful
things to me so it was terrifying to be
left on my own
if I
did things like look out of the window
or
just anything that
I like to do and that was forbidden she
would go and
tell him about it and get me into
trouble
which often led to
enormous explosions of anger and
a lot of beating and kicking and
other forms of violence EB was very even
though he was quite small and getting on
in years he was very powerful when he
was angry and he could really hurt you
when you grew up did you think other
people were living the same way as you
or were you aware that everyone outside
your house was living in a different way
I would say I think the cult tried to
hide from me how other people were
living
because they wouldn't let me for example
even look out of the window but I
inevitably did start to look out of the
window
and then I was told that these people
outside the neighbors and other people
you saw walking past were
living horrible lives
unlike the Fantastic life that I had
been blessed with
so I was never allowed to even go out of
the house
or go to school or
even go to the doctor
that was that was how I grew up
what kind of people was he getting to
live with him and stay with him
he had his fiancee who later became his
wife
and then her disabled sister
and he he used to do
campaigning among the Malaysian students
and nurses who were
living and studying in the UK
when I was born there were 10 people in
the house
and aside from my father all the rest
were women one of them was a union rep
and the other was a
nurse in a rehabilitation center so we
lived on the money that they brought in
they they had all cut off ties with
their families that was kind of
that was kind of a deal breaker for
joining the cult that you had to
keep your family at a distance and many
of them like my mum she said I have no
mother when her mother came to
the door to try to
find out
whether she was living there or not
and they were none of them were allowed
to have contact with their families
he used to say well I can't remember
word for word but the essence of it was
this
that all the feelings that they had were
actually
chains upon them preventing them from
devoting their lives fully to the
Communist course and by Ascension to him
so they had to consciously reject
anything which
aroused emotions or
a sense of
Bond or connection with anyone else they
had to
go against that and
pretend that it didn't exist or
almost like punish themselves for daring
to have such thoughts even when what he
said was clearly
wrong or clearly didn't tally it's like
saying one thing one day and something
completely different the other day it
was like they were just they were just
nod along
almost like
zombies and I think a lot of these
people were very naive and very
easily LED
and they wanted to believe in something
that was good
and it sounded very good if you heard
him speak you would really think that he
meant well
and it was
it was like there was a
a dark undercurrent
which was not immediately
noticeable to a person who was so taken
out by the message people have read the
Lord of the Rings
he reminded me the way he used to talk
of Saruman and the voice of Saruman who
used to make people believe what he said
using the power of His Voice
I I just remember
lots of time seeing people standing
around in circles listening to a b talk
and sometimes it was three or four hours
people will stand up and sometimes
people used to pass out and they would
get slapped and beaten up for passing
out
everyone would stand around in a circle
and Target one person whoever that
person was
and say all the bad things about them
and then others would just join in and
pile on that person
and reduce them to tears and
kind of
just
abuse them emotionally and verbally
when they failed to follow his
instructions they were actually harming
themselves so
what he used to say was
that he believed that he had a mind
control machine who he called Jackie
and he used to say that
when he beat people up or punished
people he was actually protecting them
from the much greater
Wrath of Jackie
Jackie was an invisible entity which he
called he used to call it the machines
when I was growing up as a child and
later on he became Jackie
the the adults in the house were the
ones who really believed in Jackie I
mean as a child growing up I kind of I
don't know if I seriously believed in it
but I didn't know any better than to
challenge it but the others in the house
the
they really believed in it and they
I don't know I don't understand how they
managed to
sink to such a level where they
accepted such things without question
but I suppose there was a an element of
they were missing that religious element
in their lives and they wanted to
believe that there was a higher power so
rather than believe in a traditional
religion they were believing in this
weird cult
what were your first experiences like of
meeting people from outside the cult I
remember when age 10
I poured water into the Airing cupboard
hoping that
they would have to call a plumber in so
that I could see someone who was
different on the rare occasions that
people visited sometimes I used to be
taken out that was the only times that I
went out of the house once a year or
once in two years when
relatives came to the house
to the park or to a museum or somewhere
like that and those were like the
highlights of my life and I
so excited about going out
but it was so rare whenever I met
someone from outside either when they
came to the house on the red or on the
rare occasions when I went out I always
thought other people seemed so much
nicer and not weird not robotic not
just freaky like the people around me
and I used to wonder why why can't I be
like them why can't I be around people
like that who talk sense you know just
you can just have an ordinary
conversation with them without all sorts
of weird ideas about Jackie and fascist
State and don't say this and don't say
that and don't do this and don't do that
and Abe would do this to you and a b is
this and you know all these treading on
eggshells about every little thing I
remember seeing someone getting
beaten up
getting a black eye
and all the other members of The Cult
were holding that person down while a b
unched her face in
when I was five years old and it was
like kind of that was
that was commonplace I remember Abe
saying to me when I disagreed with him
or
had a crush on somebody who he didn't
like or something saying that I would
bury you in the garden Who would know
if I killed you who is going to know
because nobody knows you are even here
couldn't understand why it had to be
like this I understand it I I
could understand what
up to a point
what they were trying to do but I
couldn't understand why he had to be so
unpleasant
so what would happen if somebody fell
sick they died
and did people actually die yes well my
mom
became very paranoid and seriously
mentally ill and she didn't get any help
so she committed suicide
so that was the kind of thing that
happened in the house
how old were you when your mother passed
I was 14.
did you know at that point that she was
your mother
no not until later on I I suspected but
I didn't know
did it have an impact on you
well
unfortunately I have to say it made my
life a lot better because she was
she was a horrific bully
second only to
a B and his wife the the police got
involved when my mum died because her
family
wondered what on Earth was going on when
she was in she she threw herself out of
a second floor window and was in
hospital for eight months
and her family were told that she was
traveling abroad
and then when she died
the
the hospital informed her mother that
she had died
and she was heartbroken and was like
what happened and they thought that
Something Fishy was going on so they got
the police involved and there was a
murder investigation and finally there
was a
an inquest at which
members of The Cult all went and they
lied the the cult members told the
inquest that
Sean had
fallen off the window while cleaning
and
I don't know they didn't
seem to be anyone who was
questioning that and
it just
it was just a cover-up as with
everything else
and unfortunately a lot of people just
went along with that and didn't
probe any further
when my mum was in hospital I started
reading more I used to read beforehand
but because she was always around
my ability to read was curtailed
very greatly but after she left I had a
lot more time
and I used to
read a lot of stuff and in the process
of reading I
came across things not similar to my own
story but about people like writing to
an Agony Aunt saying that my parents
won't let me go out or something and I
remember thinking oh I would like to be
able to write to an eigenyon but then
I can't write it I can't go out to post
a letter and if a letter comes to me
a b would open it first anyway so I felt
like all avenues were closed all the
time
and then there were times when I had
crushes on people like on a neighbor or
something and thinking oh I'd really
like to be able to talk to that person
but how am I going to be able to do that
when people are watching me 24 7 and
doors are always locked and windows are
locked and you can't there's always
somebody around there's at least two or
three people in any room at any one time
but I thought anything would be better
than this and even if it's not better at
least it's different
I couldn't imagine that anywhere could
be so awful as this place where
you just got into trouble just basically
for existing
so why what age were you when you
started to hatch an Escape Plan
when I was 22 I ran away from the house
and
I didn't know how to get on a bus I
didn't barely knew how to use money I
didn't know how to
navigate A to B so it was very scary
and
when I went to the police station they
kind of thought they was like someone
just running away from home because they
were not happy with their parents and it
was like an ordinary situation but
this could be kind of either I think
what they thought was they could be
resolved just by talking about it and I
didn't want to talk about what was
actually going on because my intention
was not to get
the cult members into trouble it was
just too get out of that situation
because I didn't like it
the woman who I spoke to she said she
would ring me in a couple of weeks and
a b
made sure that there were a few people
in the house when that happened
there were about three of them all
standing around me to make sure that I
said what they wanted me to say and I
they're not even put an inflection in my
voice which
would have triggered any concern on the
other side because I knew that I would
be in serious trouble if I sounded
confused or sounded like I was not
certain about what I was saying
to actually hatch the escape room was
much later I was in my late 20s I had to
enlist help from
another cult member but her name was
Josie and she was one of the
worst
lieutenants of a b next to Sean my mum
but she hated Abe's wife who was always
bullying her
so
what I did basically was comfort her
when
she was being bullied by a B's wife
Abe's wife Chanda used to tell lies
about Josie to a b and get her beaten up
so I said to her
I said but that's what you used to do
when I was a child you used to get me
beaten up by lying and then she kind of
thought yes that's terrible I don't like
that
she kind of built a
kind of a connection with me I think and
I was also very sympathetic to her when
she was being targeted because when Abe
bullied one person none of the other cup
members would befriend that person it
was like a complete banishment for a few
days until Abe decided that they were
allowed back into the fold
so
Josie would feel extremely isolated and
unhappy but I would comfort her at that
point and I did so not because not
purely because I wanted to
get her to help me to escape but because
I just thought it was unkind and I would
have loved someone to do that to me when
I was being bullied so it was like now
is my chance to
Comfort somebody who has been treated
badly and
I I wanted to do it but I started
talking to her and telling her that all
this unpleasantness in the house is due
to Abe's wife
because if I had said it was a b she
would never have accepted it because she
was she worshiped a b but she was happy
to accept that it was Abe's wife because
she she was jealous of her and hated her
because she was a bully so she we
started talking about
how bad things are and
that and I said at one point that
I want to leave this place
and this was in beginning in 2013 I said
that I will leave this house by the end
of 2014 either alive or dead
and at that point I started to lose
weight rapidly and Josie was worried
about me
based on what had happened to the other
people in the past who had not got
medical attention and had died and she
was worried that something similar was
going to happen to me
so she talked about
taking me to the hospital when
ab and chondo were out but I said I'm
not going to go to the hospital to come
back here if I'm going I'm going to go
I'm not going to come back to this place
once I go I'm that's it I'm going
so she accepted that
things were serious and
she agreed to help me
to find a way out
we decided that what we needed was a
mobile phone to be able to call out of
the house
in October was it September October
2013.
Josie bought a mobile phone when she
went out shopping with Aisha
and
we were kind of waiting for the right
time so we used to have to watch the six
o'clock news
that that was compulsory
and there was
an item about forced marriages
and underneath there was the helpline
number
for be saying that if if anyone is in a
similar situation call this number so we
didn't think it was quite accurate
because this wasn't a fast marriage
situation but we thought it might be so
memorize that number
and then
the next time when a B and his wife went
out shopping
we called it
and we managed to get through
to someone who
was very interested in the situation and
said that they would be happy to help
and finally
a date was arranged which was 25th of
October 2013 that someone will come and
pick us up
it was arranged for a day when
ab and Chanda were out shopping and I
said don't stand in front of the house
because they might notice something
going on and decide to not to go out or
something so sort of go around the
corner and and wait around the corner
and we'll come to you Josie wanted to
leave with me she was still very much
attached to the cult but she wanted to
make sure that I was safe so she decided
to leave with me we went to a refuge in
Leeds so it was flat with a number of
rooms
in it
but each room had a lock and key so it
was like
a safe room
so when ab and Chanda came back they
they according to Usher they were
calling for us and like where's
where where these people and they've
gone
so Asha was getting grilled about why
why they had disappeared and she just
said I didn't notice I was busy in the
kitchen and I didn't notice that they
had gone obviously she knew but
we had told her not to
admit to anything otherwise she may have
got beaten up according to Aisha a
couple of hours later the police came to
the door
in connection saying that they wanted to
speak to them in connection with
the two ladies who had left the house
and
Abe told
the others at that point he was chunder
and I shared just to keep quiet
and not to say anything about what was
actually going on
but I on the way to the Refuge
the police interviewed me and Josie and
I I had told them what what was that
what had been going on so they went into
collect our shares well so all three of
us went
from London to Leeds together
and he was arrested
he was arrested about a month later
him he and Chanda were arrested but she
was not
charged
his jail term was 20 for 23 years he was
sentenced to imprisonment and I mean I
was not particularly happy about that I
don't like the idea of imprisoning
people I mean since I had been
held captive for 30 years I didn't
exactly want to
put someone else in prison he felt like
taking Revenge which is not not my thing
at all
but that's how it worked out so
did you ever see him again did you visit
him in prison
no I I didn't know how to arrange I
wanted to
talk to him and sort of
tell him that there's no I don't hate
him or something but I just couldn't
live in the way he wanted me to live
but it never
it never happened and he passed away
last year and well
that's something I suppose I don't know
can't always
have it the way you want it can you
and how about for you after 30 years
raised in
in a small house in cramped conditions
it must have been very very difficult to
adjust to the openness of the outside
world
yes it was everything was so difficult
and I didn't expect that at all when I
first came out I kind of while waiting
the house and fantasizing about Escape I
kind of thought once they were out of
the way I would just be able to do what
I wanted and I didn't
count on having
disabilities and health issues so I
struggled to
struggle to move about and then I have
issues of
getting lost and
just get feeling
overwhelmed in in a large space
that was a big problem at first because
getting from A to B learning to cross
the road
learning to take public transport that
was it was scary as hell
I suppose with meeting people it's when
people ask questions hoping that they
won't ask too many questions about
where I went to school or what I was
doing or where I was from because it was
embarrassing to have to talk about
what where I came from I mean I grew up
it was anger and hatred in the house and
the one thing that I never want to be is
to be that person myself
so I was at times very angry and very
hateful when I was stuck in the cult and
I did have bad ideas about wanting to do
harm to people and things like that
because it was just so
what you call it unpleasant and when
when you're put under extreme
pressure sometimes the dark side comes
out of any one of us I have always loved
the idea of
people who forgive others because I
think that is such a nice thing to do
and after having spent the first 30
years of my life in prison now I want to
be free and you can't be free if you're
hitching other people or wanting to take
revenge on others it's it's such a
pointless and stupid way to live
[Music]
whilst everybody was having their orgies
free love sex they would no longer be
permitted to enjoy the sex for each
other they had to fantasize that they
were actually having sex with Jesus
um men included